carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
más
[Música]
bienvenidos a esta nueva edición de
nuestro programa carrusel de las artes
desde el festival biarritz américa
latina' en esta ocasión vamos a
conversar con dos invitados de la
sección literaria en este prestigioso
festival del país vascofrancés
[Música]
conversaremos con el escritor eduardo
fernando varela autor de la marca del
viento su primera novela que ha
suscitado gran interés en francia
también con nosotros en esta ocasión la
editora anna marie métailié quien rindió
homenaje en el festival de biarritz a su
amigo el escritor chileno luis sepúlveda
fallecido en abril pasado por causa de
cómic y descubriremos a los ganadores de
la competencia cinematográfica del
festival biarritz y smith
[Música]
pocas veces una novela ha tenido tanto
éxito en una primera edición y es el
caso de la novela que vamos a presentar
el día de hoy un road trip un viaje
magnífico por la patagonia y tenemos con
nosotros al autor de esta novela la
marca del viento con una primera edición
en francés
bajo el título patagonia ruta 203
eduardo fernando varela muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros aquí en
el festival de biarritz y en nuestro
programa carrusel de las artes bueno
muchas gracias muchas gracias a ti es un
honor por la invitación y ahora en este
libro usted nos invita a un viaje por
una patagonia poblada de personajes
extraños extravagantes cuéntenos cómo
nació esta idea y esa idea de la
patagonia una pata una inventada y muy
mágica claro yo traté de inventar una
base han visto que la patagonia ha sido
ya contada magistralmente por muchos
autores por chadwick por sepúlveda por
bonnie por muchos otros se trate de
imaginaron la patagonia distinta
imaginar la inventar la la patagonia
y ver qué tipo de personajes pueden
hacer en la estepa estéril seca árida
barrida por el viento y bueno el fin del
mundo uno tiene la sensación de estar en
un donde se acaba el mundo y eso fue lo
que me me incentivó a reconstruir un
ambiente ahí y ahora esta historia en el
fin del mundo es la historia de parker
un camionero que atraviesa de norte a
sur de este a oeste este inmenso terreno
que es la patagonia y que consigue el
amor
de manera inesperada abrupta a que lo
hizo que lo empujó a abordar personajes
así un camionero una chica en una en una
feria ambulante claro yo traté de
reconstruir una patagonia que más que un
territorio
fuera un océano un mar un lugar en donde
la gente
está a la deriva de hecho un camionero
que está siempre a la deriva y un parque
de diversiones ambulantes son dos
derivas que en determinado momento se
encuentran detrás de reconstruir eso y
de hecho todo tiene ruedas no hay raíces
no hay casas de poblaciones precarias
todo todo se mueve con ruedas un camión
el parque de diversiones y yo creo que
no hay un solo árbol en el relato
eso es una son personajes a la deriva
como no creo que nos pasa a todos es el
viento los empuja de un lado a otro hay
una una frase en argentina que se usa
que se dice cada tanto y es este dios
los cría y el viento los amontona el
viento los junta y lo que es algún modo
de ello les pasa eso y justamente ese
viento es casi un personaje más en esta
en esta novela
sí sí sí y desde el viento tengo una
experiencia particular en viajes
sucesivos que hice la patagonia luego
pude experimentar este viento constante
que a veces no te deja abrir las puertas
de los autos y si lo haces en contra no
puedes abrir la puerta y si lo haces al
revés la puerta abuela es una presencia
constante que puede llegar a ponerte de
muy mal humor hacemos este viaje por la
patagonia de la mano de este señor con
camionero parker que es casi un
personaje aparte completamente solo en
su camión y de hecho no le gusta estar
en compañía de la gente claro es un poco
un ermitaño me acuerdo que una vez un
camionero me vino a saludar que estaba
ahí haciendo probaturas aprovisionándose
de víveres y de combustible y me
saludaba de un modo muy efusivo muy
afectuoso yo no entendía muy bien por
qué y después me di cuenta que ellos
eran las últimas poblaciones y éramos
los últimos seres humanos que veían
antes de atravesar una o dos o una
semana de rutas de tierra de rutas así
así son yo veía que estos hombres eran
como navegantes que iban a descubrir
tierras nuevas
en el fin del mundo y así se me de se me
ocurrió que de ahí nace este personaje
del parque que bueno no es uno que anda
dando muchos abrazos en la vida como
aquel otro pero
pero son ermitaños muchísimas gracias
eduardo fernando varela por este tiempo
que nos concedió durante su agenda aquí
en biarritz recordándoles a las personas
que nos ven este libro la marca del
viento con español patagonia ruta 203
por las ediciones métele muchísimas
gracias a ustedes y ahora vamos a seguir
nuestro programa y vamos a conocer a los
ganadores de esta edición 2020 del
festival biarritz américa latina en la
competencia cinematográfica muchos
premios pero pocos ganadores presentes
el sábado por la noche en el cierre del
festival biarritz américa latina por
causa de ccoo vida el máximo galardón el
premio el abrazo al mejor largometraje
fue para la película ofrenda de un joven
cineasta argentino de 22 años juan
mónaco quien jugó en esta cinta con la
percepción del tiempo
ha seleccionado la pt para pasarla y
luego
he sido
no sé me parece una labor que el jurado
de biarritz premio al venezolano porque
tienen por la fortaleza película
personal protagonizada por su propio
padre y que aborda su adicción al
alcohol
me contenta muchísimo el premio el
jurado y
y ojalá estuviese mi papá aquí para
compartirlo conmigo pero pero bueno sé
que estará viendo esto y qué bueno que
ojalá ayude que la película llegue a
otros lugares yo lo veo como que hicimos
algo juntos y que que vale la pena y que
fue súper grato y que hicimos algo ella
el uruguayo alex piperno se alzó con el
premio del sindicato de críticos por
chico ventana también quisiera tener un
submarino cinta que teje vínculos entre
mundos paralelos para mí es una alegría
obviamente importantísima de hecho es el
primer festival al que puedo venir
presencialmente desde el estreno de la
película en berlín en febrero fueron
diseño de trabajo 10 años de no entender
mucho nada sigo sin entender pero por lo
menos me lo solo o lo que parece
otros premios en las categorías cortos y
documentales completaron el palmarés de
este festival en el país vascofrancés
[Música]
y seguimos en el festival biarritz
américa latina y ahora le vamos a dar la
palabra a una mujer que ha tenido un rol
fundamental en la difusión de la
literatura latinoamericana aquí en
francia y metería de fundadora y
directora de las ediciones métele
muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros
buenos días estoy muy feliz de estar
aquí allá y ahora estará usted aquí en
biarritz para rendir homenaje a alguien
que nos dejó al principio de esta
epidemia coronavirus el chileno luis
sepúlveda y una persona que era amiga
personal de usted y además que tiene una
historia con la casa métailié porque
usted fue una de las primeras la primera
que publicó un viejo que leía novelas de
amor así que me imagino que este
homenaje para usted es importante sí es
muy importante porque
convive con luis sepúlveda durante 28
años y nuestra relación empezó por la
lectura de su libro un libro totalmente
desconocido y que cambió nuestro
encontro cambió su vida y mi vida cambió
su vida porque el lanzamiento y la
manera como los lectores franceses y los
libreros que fueron fundamentales en la
difusión de su obra porque hicieron este
texto y los vendieron lo aconsejaron y
vendió así sin bueno habíamos vendido 36
mil ejemplares cuando salió el primer
artículo de prensa y los libreros
empezaron a considerarme como una
editorial que se pudiera considerar
entonces me cambió totalmente la vida me
dio una
autoridad como le gustaría que lo
recordaran al y sepúlveda como este
formidable contador de historias
narrador qué es eso y también este es un
hombre que practicaba un estilo y seco
que cada palabra tenía su peso y
que cuida mucho mucho la manera de
ignorar era un narrador de historias
compulsivas de una cena con él era un
viaje total pero cuando lo escribía lo
escribía con una nitidez una precisión
que era estupenda estupenda era
importante hacer este homenaje aquí en
francia usted nos decía que el público
francés lo dio a conocer si el público
francés lo dio a conocer y tener aquí la
presencia de carmen yáñez sepúlveda es
importante también porque la historia de
amor es entre luís y pulida y su mujer
que fue su primera mujer que se
separaron y volvieron es una historia de
amor es extraordinaria y hay poemas que
escribió
louis cuando tenía 20 años para esta
mujer también
y carmen yáñez escribe una poesía
también como luchó así muy sencilla pero
muy trabajada y que toca porque lo que
lo importante de la obra de sepúlveda es
que toca al lector y despierta en él lo
mejor lo mejor de sí mismo pues
muchísimas gracias por esas palabras tan
inspiradas y por regalarnos un minuto de
su tiempo aquí en el festival de
biarritz si parece un homenaje a luís
sepúlveda que hemos podido hacer aquí
también nosotros en carrusel de las
artes muchas gracias a martín
muchas gracias a vosotros
carrusel de las artes fue al encuentro
de la esposa del fallecido luis
sepúlveda quien nos regaló en biarritz
el último poema escrito a su compañero
de vida
éramos tan felices y no lo sabíamos
ignorantes de la luz que circundaba la
inocencia éramos tan felices amor mío
con el calor de nuestras manos juntas
cursando todos los caminos y riéndonos
de los obstáculos de piedra o granizo
que nos intentaban parar esa carrera
irresponsable de la felicidad éramos tan
felices y no nos enterábamos de la
dimensión de la vida de la invisible
amenaza de la larga sombra del miedo no
lo sabíamos nosotros irreverentes
amándonos con proyecciones de futuro hoy
yo no pienso más allá de mañana cuando
espero tu prueba de vida
dicha por otros
[Música]
ya nos toca despedir este programa
especial de carrusel de las artes desde
biarritz y los vamos a dejar
agradeciéndoles muchísimo por su
sintonía cuídense mucho y hasta la
próxima